bonjour nous sommes dans sa hotte caddie
avec ce matin à notre invité michel
branchi bonjour bonjour à toutes et à
tous bonjour à vos auditeurs
voilà élus de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique michel
branchi donc vous êtes en tant que
conseiller territorial président de la
commission des finances de l'assemblée à
l'assemblée de martinique donc et puis
il faut le préciser quand même vous êtes
aussi membre dirigeant du parti
communiste martiniquais le pcm tout à
fait le pcm qui est membre du grand
ensemble et voilà grands ensembles et
qui est une des composantes de la
majorité qui avaient gagné des élections
à la ctm en décembre 2015
alors nous y reviendrons à la ctm
puisque le mandat la mandature est
vraiment là sur le point de s'achever
est justement ce matin nous avons appris
que l'exécutif donc et que le premier
ministre jean castex jean castex va
proposer dans quelques heures aux
parlementaires d'organiser les élections
régionales alors chez nous ces élections
territoriales puisque c'est une
collectivité territoriale que nous avons
et d'organiser ces élections
finalement les 20 et 27 juin un des des
dates qui avait déjà été reporté qui a
prévu pour les 13 et 20 juin
et donc là il sera demandé une semaine
de plus nous dit-on selon la version
gouvernementale pour une la vaccination
un délai plus long pour que la
vaccination
effectivement soit plus étendue et une
semaine de plus aussi pour faire
campagne c'est une bonne nouvelle selon
vous michel branchi pour de toute façon
là le grand semblait et nounous carré
pour que nous parler nous parler parce
que nous nions bilan positif à l'effort
et nous les nuits des perspectives pour
à la fois soutien de la population et
surtout pour amorcer en changement de
modèle de développement économique donc
ces macabres compagnie shell bon si sa
carence des autres que l'élection
catherine coole en juin et pas en
octobre par exemple ou l'année prochaine
n'importe qui si une solution situation
car angers nous parce que nous qu'à
travailler d'ailleurs bien ouais que
pendant que tout le monde a avoué qu
imiter le cac continue travail au
service du peuple martiniquais jusqu'au
bout de la mandature de donc que la
mandature soit en juin en octobre ou un
décembre la nounou là pour travailler
bas peuple
oui mais les conditions de la campagne
électorale sont forcément différentes
avec des dalles qui seraient les 20 et
27 juin
bien entendu octobre l'année prochaine
là ça donne des conditions d'une
campagne électorale est clair de deux
mois à peine deux mois
et puis qui sera encore plus singulière
peut-être que celle de l'an dernier
sipa la nuit ses passagers les élections
municipales
oui non mais attendez ça veut dire qui
aura pas beaucoup de meetings sur le
terrain les choses à faire beaucoup
par voie numérique enfin bon goût
manière de faire campagne à la condition
que je mens lis certains baggaley
notamment le conseil scientifique bon à
condition que les conditions d'égalité
des candidats à la communication soit
soit strictement réglementée bon
autrement dit il faut que pendant la
période de la campagne électorale de
manière très scrupuleuse les moins les
moyens soient équitables donc mais ceci
dit bon entre panier cependant qu'à
décider c'est au cas décidé bataillon
français en fonction de calcul politique
président oui répond pas tellement chaud
pour une élection puisqu'il paie qui
savent qu'en général les élections à
1000 à intermédiaire pour un exécutif
généralement défavorable bon en plus ils
savent que niant au rejet du président
des riches
donc ils paient élections élections
régionales et départementales
vous pensez qu'il y avait une trace de
soirée bien sûr c'est qu'en février
c'est plus serré à droite la droite
notamment qui majoritaire parmi les
maires la droite plutôt pour le maintien
des élections donc mais ça c'est devant
les maires les maires ici ont été
consultés en extrême urgence un le temps
d'un week-end aussi est ce qui nous est
revenu hier c'est que ceux qui avaient
répondu donc le retour des réponses et
que c'était moitié-moitié quoi y avait
cinquante concerts des verts qui était
notamment un report éventuellement même
voir jusqu'à l'année prochaine
et puis 50% qui disent ah bah non faut
faut les tenir ça y est ce parce que
parce qu'il ya eu des élections dans
d'autres pays d'europe où ailleurs dans
le monde en amérique du sud aussi
récemment et des opérations de vote se
sont déroulées
oui parce que d'abord les mains les
maires ses yeux 40gb les bureaux de vote
auraient eux savent que les conditions
pas toujours réunies pour préserver la
santé des personnels donc l'aspect
sanitaire parce que au cas du moins
aussi même de plus pour la vaccination
bon bah ça combien millions moun yo pé
vacciner un email mais c'est pas un
ciment niqab amon tanoh l'immunité
collective
sauf sauf si sauf si les assesseurs les
personnes qui doivent eux le déroulement
des opérations sur le terrain moment
c'est à dire que va leur faciliter leur
matière sur le plan strictement
sanitaires sur le plan strictement sanit